we're going to be making butter today
you can turn the butter we're gonna be
true I've never made cookies from
scratch before because I'm a woman on
the Dow I'm already nervous about that
but I also think it might take too much
time and too much money to make it zero
waste Zee Rosie Rosie zero I'm gonna try
to make chocolate chip cookies but with
zero trash I'm super excited to make
these cookies zero ways I think I need
to go to specialty places and multiple
places to get this package free so I
think the level of time is going to
definitely take longer than I would
normally money I don't know so we need
to get some flour sugar chocolate what
school tears are not that I'm good at
measuring but we can get kind of more
exactly that we need for the recipe
rather than I find too much we're gonna
take a picture of the pluie to learn at
the register we can tell them a blue
number and they can also deduct the
weight of the bag for some reason they
don't have regular flour they only have
almond flour so we're actually going to
be having gluten-free cookies on
accident we wanted the gluten but yeah
it's okay I love how childhood chip is
my favorite cookie I love chocolate chip
you know why because it's me and most of
my hoes I'm the chocolate chip and
they're the cookie we are making Alvin's
cookies that's their way so oven has two
different kinds of chocolate chips in
his recipe but at our local eco-friendly
grocery store we can only find one so
Alvin you're only getting one out of us
okay we're playing prints at the store
dazzle you there's just something about
fresh out the oven und a nightgown you
got your bonnet on you know your makeup
is off you turn on your Netflix you got
a glass of milk
oka milk though because I'm eco-friendly
ho we're gonna be making
oat milk with rolled oats it's very easy
because we gotta have milk with our
chocolate chip cookie absolutely we're
gonna be making butter because we
couldn't find package free butter yes
I'm ready to churn that butter daddy
we're gonna use heavy cream this is in a
returnable glass bottles so if we return
it once we're done with it we can get
some money back we found some vanilla
extract in glass do you want to be extra
0yz you can make your own with vanilla
pods and alcohol well yeah but we're
just gonna get any less we went through
the store and we found the cheapest
packaged versions of what it would take
to make chocolate chip cookies yeah so
we added up the total and it came out to
38 53 so we got to see how the package
free version stacks up now I don't know
if it's gonna be cheaper or more
expensive we'll see so we got mostly
everything package free except for the
creamer and the vanilla extract and of
course the salt I mean we already have
at home so yes and then the eggs already
got at the farmers market and baking
soda I actually already have I got from
a zero-waste store called sustained LA
so let's go make these cookies yeah
Alvin I hope you make you proud how you
feeling I'm feeling great we prepped
everything so we have everything ready
tasty style tasty look but we're not
tasty producers not at all home chefs
home shows we're doing our best here
that's right don't judge us we must be
the first thing that we're doing is
making the butter mm-hmm let's do that
so we have heavy whipping cream and this
is our first piece of trash this piece
of paper and also this seal Wow
yeah can nothing ever just truly be
zero-waste
society get better so what is butter
butter is just like shaking heavy cream
I think you're lying
well watch we're gonna we're about to
make butter right now we're gonna shake
this and totally get butter it's a
little yeah dude dude start shaking
shake it shake it shake it like a
Polaroid but I don't recommend doing
this at home we're just really going for
zero waste for you but like yeah
honestly I'm sure you guys have better
things to do with your time with us it's
like we're praying please we're praying
to the butter god please turn oh I think
I did it I think I did it well so this
is how you know it's butter it's because
the buttermilk has separated from the
butter did yours become butter yet I
don't know I'm gonna shake it a couple
more times okay let's check it hopefully
and but a master longer than mine look
at yours ooh that literally took no time
but it was a decent amount of effort it
was thank you with everything I had
we're pouring out our buttermilk let's
try it
whoa what is this mouth
like butter on my bagels it's just
melted milk how much is it that is only
1/3 cup of butter we need 2/3 cup we're
kind of tired after turning our own
butter proud of us so we're going to put
this whipping cream in the food
processor and see if we can make butter
like that do you think it's better it's
better now we're just gonna make with
this as a recipe calls for melted butter
2/3 goes well I'll get the cookies okay
okay so the first step is give the bowl
okay we're gonna get the two sugars now
we put the salt and we mix it do you
think we're making almond crowd
absolutely not he just makes it look
more graceful I know but uh me up babe
homemade butter oh I can smell that [ __ ]
from a mile away
next is a mmm next we're gonna put the
vanilla but we do have a safety seal
means Louise Isis break how many how
much oh look Oh surprise trash Wow
what okay wait we only need one safety
seal yeah okay we don't need to pick one
people press trash square shush 1/2
spoon of vanilla it smells really good
we got almond flour because we couldn't
find regular flour at that store for
some reason now we're gonna do the
baking soda too and then we just shimmy
shimmy shimmy shimmy shimmy
this is pretty much now full-blown
cookie island said to be like gentle
when you're mixing it because you get
you shouldn't over mix it mmm
you ready for those choco chocolate
chips choco choco choco chips yeah let's
do it
I'll pour you stir okay okay we got to
try the dough don't do this at home kids
cuz you raw egg
[Music]
mmm it's like decadent mm-hmm very sweet
we're gonna use our B's rap which is an
alternative to plastic wrap
reusable it's cloth covered in bees wax
now we're gonna chose for 30 minutes
okay guys so we're gonna be making oh
well
Oh Malik is actually really easy to make
plant milks are easy to make you don't
really need to buy them you can always
just make them so we have 1 cup of oats
and we have 4 cups of water it's
basically just 1 to 4 that's the ratio
so you can make a bigger or a smaller
batch whoa and we can have plant milk in
like 30 seconds watch us go
okay wait okay that's it it's so easy
dude you don't even buy anything now we
just strain it and if you make milk or
cashew milk you don't have to strain so
those are some even easier milks we're
gonna pour it into this bag you can use
an old t-shirt even you can use a nut
milk bag you can use cheesecloth oh
we're going to put the cookies on the
cookie tray we chilled our cookie dough
for 30 or that mean deep now we're just
gonna scoop out cookies so we're gonna
put them in the oven
[Music]
I'm gonna salt it a little bit love a
good sea salt the cookies you know they
didn't turn out as great as almonds I
mean again not tasty Buddhism I think
the almond flour compromised the
structure of the cookies they're kind of
just like falling apart
for sure but they do taste really good
Big D tastes really really good
you know zero waste is a journey not a
destination so how much trash should we
end up making I would say that we did
pretty good
the only trash we have is from heavy
cream and the vanilla and the only
compost was this one eggshell hmm good
mm-hmm how do we do on money the zero
waste version actually came in cheaper
in the package first whoa zero waste
came in at nine dollars and 64 cents
less I love that do people get points at
salmon because they made them cookies
I'm gonna eat all the cookies before us
and uh that's what's gonna get cold
we make them new cookies that don't fall
apart we'll use regular flowers you
don't know if Santa's gluten-free
[Music]